let's um let's laugh as we watch the
demise I have this tweet from leftism
for you just another day in New York
City insane at Belle fries and NYC some
women got angry that extra sauce cost I
think was a dollar fifty and so they
just ransacked the whole place jumping
over smashing everything attacking
people and just destroying everything
why is there so many videos like this
something is happening in places like
New York get out of the city is the only
thing I can say
the official story apparently yeah okay
1.75 women destroy Manhattan business
leaving employees bloodied for a dollar
seventy five
gonna get their extra sauce what's
happening
um people are disarmed and unable to
defend themselves the first thing I saw
when I watched this video for I was
thinking about it from the person's
perspective that was being attacked and
having their their business destroyed or
wherever they were what if they were
armed and they fired at the attackers
would that have been Justified they go
to jail in New York you could have a
major problem
um
I personally know somebody who uh had a
real if if the governor himself didn't
get involved in New Jersey it would have
went a lot different for him and that
was defending himself and his wife
against an attacker
equal force in his own home came home
from work but he didn't use equal force
uh or at least attempt that's an insane
it's what Define equal force exactly how
do you know if the guy in front of you
is a black belt or not right Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu MMA oh well officer I shot him
because I saw his ears he had
cauliflower ears that justified equal
force right how do you have no you have
no idea when I when when we had uh back
in when I was in Jersey we had a crazy
pedo guy try to break in like no and you
know he's like tell my story and like we
hear it's like three in the morning I
call the cops I'm like yo and the cop
said to me he's like if it were me I'd
answer the door with a shotgun and I was
like okay so I went on my journey trying
to figure out how to get a gun it was
very difficult I was lied to left and
right finally figured out how to get one
and then I was sold basically the way it
was broken down to me
if you're in your house someone breaks
in in New Jersey you have to flee your
home yeah you have to jump out the
window or whatever get away you can't
only if you're cornered and then I'm
like okay how do you define corner I
don't know you're going to get arrested
you're going to get charged with murder
and then you're going to argue to the
jury why it wasn't actually murdered yes
so it's like okay so a guy can break to
my house and I'm I can't defend myself
without getting charged with felonies
and arrested that's right I'm leaving
this day that's what I said I'm out and
in this case it was uh he was being I
mean he was messed up he was being
brutally assaulted with a piece of
firewood that was by the fireplace the
guy just took it and just started you
know viciously beating him over that
with it so cracking his face so he was a
plumber and he took uh one of the box
cutter knives he still had his tool belt
on he came home from work and he found
the guy in there with his wife
and assaulting her wow and he was not as
strong as the guy so he he got he the
guy was on top I'm hitting him with wood
he took a box cutter they arrested him
charged him he had a later demonstrate
that he was in New Jersey right yes this
is the annoying thing because I had a
lot of people say to me no Tim you're
wrong New Jersey's partial castle
doctrine you can defend yourself in your
own home no no it's not and it's crazy
that anyone would think New Jersey what
do they call one of the evil seven
that's what Governors call them uh what
what allow this no no you're in your
home
and so the way the house we had was set
up is the my room there's no way out you
jump out the window from the second
floor so if someone broke in I'm like I
got one path I have no choice so I see
someone break it in my house
and I'm supposed to stop and and try and
discern do they have a weapon are they
gonna attack me in my own home
like I said just wait and find out
that's New Jersey for you you need the
governor to come in and try to basically
help you based on a castle doctrine rule
no no lawyer is going to walk into a
court and argue that to get you off it
was crazy
um and that story is a really tragic
Ending by the way oh the whole family
was destroyed over it it was just
terrible West Virginia is a bit
different a little bit West Virginia I
it's it's actually kind of crazy
depending on who you ask obviously you
want to be reasonable but if you're out
on your property in the middle of the
night and someone's trespassing on your
land you are in many circumstances
justified in using lethal Force against
them now not entirely it depends on uh
standing your ground someone's
trespassing you have no assumption like
you have no no duty to make assumptions
about who they are what they're doing if
they're on your property late at night
you feel threatened now if it's during
the day and you see someone walking on
your land you have to be like hey get
off leave now or else but uh Maryland's
a bit better not that great not much
better than New Jersey so I we we've
talked about all this stuff in Maryland
you have a you don't have a duty to
retreat from your home but you do have a
duty to retreat to your home so if
you're outside and someone starts
walking on the property you have to tell
them to leave if they don't you go into
your house go inside okay if they then
try to enter you are Justified using
force and I think the reason this
probably happens is because Maryland
although it is still a very awful gun
gun right State you still have Western
uh Western Maryland which wants to be
West Virginia in West Virginia it's
basically were you reasonable in trying
to avoid harm you don't have to retreat
to your house it's your property we're
not going to make assumptions and that
makes sense too and the issue is in West
Virginia your property is probably a big
piece of land yeah so if you're on
different situations right if you're on
10 acres of open land and you're you
know doing something on your property
you can't necessarily Retreat to your
house so that's why it's a bit different
but West Virginia is a bit better and
then you've got like Texas and Florida
Florida basically alike make more than
make my day laws or something yeah make
my day you're basically uh somebody's
walking on your yard they don't respond
you're good to put one in their left
cheek at least you know I mean it's it's
you know but again there have been
pushes
um in the last 10 years especially saw
with Trayvon Martin that was a national
case they tried to come after the stand
your ground but George Zimmerman was
acquitted because he was in that case
it's a perfect example I felt like he
was reasonably he had a reasonable fear
that his life was in danger well he was
on the ground he was getting his head
punched in the face repeatedly that's
right and the media lied about
everything as they always do and then
you actually ended up seeing this in the
surveillance footage one we learned
Zimmerman was a Mexican guy and his face
was bloodied up I remember that that was
that Zimmerman was following Trayvon
Martin and then Martin was like hey stop
following me and the guy was like uh I
have a reason to suspect you're doing
something and then Trayvon jumped on him
basically we don't know exactly what
happened we know that Zimmerman was like
driving in his truck he sees Trayvon
Martin with neighborhood watch yeah like
walking through these yards and then a
confrontation ensued he called 9-1-1 and
said hey this guy looks pretty
suspicious he's like wearing a hoodie
and then they said you know describe him
to us NBC takes that audio and removes
the questioning from the 9-1-1 so you
just hear Zimmerman being like he's
suspicious he looks black even though
it's not what he said they asked him
uh a fight broke out for some reason
Trayvon had him on the ground and he was
doing what's called a ground and pound
where he was pummeling him yeah and then
Zimmerman the ref will pull you off an
MMA Zimmerman on the ground because
that's the means the fight's over at
that exactly Zimmerman on the ground
pull out his gun and fired into his
chest and then the media lied about
everything yeah and they claimed that he
was a racist white guy profiling a black
teenager and it's like Zimmerman's
Mexican it's a Florida neighborhood
watch thing uh Trayvon was was beating
him up
you know what I think happened I think
Zimmerman was overzealous I think he was
probably like I'm neighborhood watch
yeah Trayvon Martin was like
disrespected and insulted by it said
screw you who are you you can't tell me
what to do two guys got into a fight one
guy had a gun that's what happens this
narrative about a racist white guy he's
like Zimmerman wasn't even a cop he was
just totally irrelevant so that's the
narrative they run with and now I saw
this thing about like it's like gen Z
and Millennials running for office and
then it's one guy and he was like a
racist white man killed Trayvon Martin
and that woke me up and I'm like this
dude doesn't even read he just got memes
off the internet he believes the memes
and now we've got to deal with
governance based on me he's having that
dream where he woke up in his dream but
he's still sleeping but he thinks he
woke up but he's like but why is reality
so still so weird because you're still
sleeping bro so look these these these
uh New York is well what's this is my
the reason I brought it up do you think
that these big cities are gonna
eventually start laxing gun laws and be
like we need the civilians to step up
and help us police our city because the
cops can't do it I saw Philadelphia
almost looked like a raid where there's
like 100 or more people on the street
just screaming and fighting and like
four cops I think were present
completely uncapable I mean what at some
point you tap the militia and you're
like yo we need help San Francisco they
were raiding those uh those stores they
just run in and steal everything and run
on yeah you can't civilization New York
has a history of that too they had uh
and a name is escaping me but they would
run around with the red on something
angels I think they were called and they
were basically it really when uh mayor
started with a d before Giuliani uh the
the city was a wreck so the town came
you know the city each Borough had their
own angels that would come and they man
they police the Subways I remember them
actually remember the streets yes that's
coming back it's scary that's my that
was my point this stuff will Guardian
Angels the guardian angels thank you and
one of them even ran for mayor once
recently non-profit International
Volunteer organization and they did they
did the job they would affect citizens
arrests and everything so did the mayor
ask for their help nope they just stood
up and we're like did it militia time
they just well you know the story of the
subway vigilante right I don't know no
so uh do you know the story I do yeah I
mean I was young but I mean it was big
news you were in New York at the time
yeah you want to tell the story and now
I just remember this guy was running
around basically uh you know being well
it was one manger it was it it was one
guy right it turned out to be a group it
was one guy and he was on the subway and
he I think he shot what was it three or
five people
uh and then he was accused major breath
of being racist yeah that he racially
profiled some black men and shot him he
said he was being mugged and so he
defended himself with an illegal weapon
I think I think it might be what no the
gum was illegal I think so yeah so yeah
people both sides of the aisle you know
constantly outside but he was a folk
hero in New York yeah the crime was so
big shirts yeah people were just like
Yay fight back the crime was so bad
unassuming white guy you know like
middle right middle aged I think he was
I mean very unassuming and then people
of course looked at him like yeah this
guy's trying to be a hero he was
basically what they did to Richard
Jewell the left tried to do to him you
know what's Richard Jewelry he was a
security guard uh in Atlanta when the
bombing went off during what the
Olympics or something right so yeah and
they made a movie about it they did to
make a movie about him uh they tried
accusing him of being the bomber yeah he
was the guy he was actually the hero he
was the hero who cleared the area out I
mean the media killed this man man yeah
they killed him they ran his health into
the ground and his heart literally gave
up that's that's something it was yeah
the Centennial Olympic Park darling 1996
Summer Olympics that's right it was
security for the music that was going on
there at the time and he saw suspicious
pack every by the way all the cops there
were feds around they always mocked him
said he's the overzealous cop want a
baby he was a deputy in a neighboring
town at one point but he was right about
that book pack he was right and he
cleared everybody out and he saved who
knows how many lies but the feds had
nowhere to start
so they looked right at the they looked
right at Richard Jewell they realized
the feds fall before it was the Met the
media this is one of the reasons the
country's falling apart I made a video
man I think it's been four years
talking about why men are no longer
helping women and children I read this
story about a guy who was in a store
and uh This Woman's female journalist
saw him uh walk walking down like the
island there's a little kid who's crying
and alone
she looks to this guy he stops turns
around and immediately runs away
she sees people come up to help the kid
once she realized the kid's safe she
runs up to the guy and asks him why
didn't you help this kid and he says are
you kidding I'd be accused of the being
the kidnapper or something I'm not going
anywhere near that kid yeah and she was
like this man saw child in distress and
ran away because he would be accused and
so there's another story where a woman
was being beaten in the subway and
everyone just watched and then she got
really mad like why aren't the men
standing up and protecting me it's like
because nobody wants to be involved
because the legal ramifications are you
go to jail if you try and stop them this
was four years ago now look at New York
City yeah what would happen you got
these women smashing up this rest this
this burger place or whatever Bell fries
whatever it is and they're ripping
things apart they're throwing things at
this guy what would he what would happen
if he took any
weapon to defend himself
they go crazier they'd get even more
Angry they'd attack him even more you'd
be a frenzy the guys would then be like
whoa oh and then more people would jump
in What if he then pulled out a gun
somebody that's part of gun you get a
shootout
then if this guy defended himself not
only that the city would probably come
after him so he does nothing these three
women I guess have been arrested and
charged over over what happened but
but no it's not something if you break
into my place of business and you're
doing this I should be allowed to stop
you for sure what's your opinion not New
York it's like the protests in in the
summer of love like you had to just put
up with your business
the cause is always more important than
people there's this meme they're like
people keep saying it's it's I I
understand that's wrong that a black man
lost his life but but it's wrong that
buildings are being destroyed and you
should be saying I understand it's wrong
the buildings are destroyed but it's
worse than a black man lost his life and
I'm like uh how about this we all agree
that innocent and unarmed people should
not be killed that doesn't justify you
burning down or looting the neighborhood
and it's nothing to do with each other
this is the game they play they'll
what's the argument for this stuff the
Looting and the cast and the destruction
what's the argument yeah why normally
they have some kind of social justice
angle that they want to they want the
greater good there's no greater good
here there's a dollar 75 for extra sauce
why why isn't the right leading with
this story why is the right always just
responding they are never I was just
gonna say they're never really proactive
that's what separates I would say I
think why Ron DeSantis is really
starting to gain traction with some
people but yeah it's still reactive yeah
he's starting to get a little bit more
reactive but for the first year or so he
was singing like he understood they got
to call the shots call the shots uh but
the right doesn't do that even Trump
after a while they started to pin him
into it they're kind of addicted to that
defensive posture and feeling beaten
down cowards yeah I'm willing women's
syndrome kind of thing even if
Republicans went in November they're not
going to do anything I don't think they
will Tim honestly we've been down this
road before and I don't mean to get you
know I don't mean to be Johnny raincloud
to some of you at home but look 2010
give us the house we'll repeal Obamacare
oh yeah right we need the Senate we need
the Senate give it to us in 2014. we'll
we'll get it done then they finally get
a president willing to sign it and they
fold thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there